elle est trop forte vous voyez tout de
suite donc prendre le centimètre pour
vérifier un peu cruel pour la taille
nous avons 75 cm c'est trop faut pour
les hanches 98 c'est encore beaucoup
trop pour la poitrine salle les moins
on a tout de même 89 pour un mètre 60 il
faut ramener ses mesures environ à 90 au
maximum de tour de hanche 60 de tour de
taille 58 si l'on pouvait il faut
aplatir creuser tout ça il faut donc la
fermer grillée il faut la faire maigrir
évidemment il faut taffer le coût
lui-même est impacté voyez-vous tout ça
le coup peut devenir plus long il est
impacté parce que trop épais d'ici le
bas du visage est empâté ça se fait très
bien maigrir avec les plaques des
plaques que nous mettons au visage le
maquillage vulgaire évidemment outré
mais faussements outrés ils se nous
permettait la coiffure le chignon
d'abord et mal fait le chignon ne lui va
pas